welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness seemed like the
perfect place to introduce an iron man
variant from another universe the baxter
foundation of the illuminati and
universe 838 had ultron sentries
designed by someone and even an
unoccupied open seat on their panel yet
the screenwriter michael waldron
confirmed that while he definitely
wanted to pursue tom cruise as an
alternate iron man no one actually
reached out to cruz and he was never
really an option shocker the rumors were
false and considering how the other fan
cast illuminati members turned out
that's good news for crews while
rebooting tony stark with a multiversal
variant seems like something we all want
the truth is the genius playboy
billionaire philanthropist's
irreplaceability is actually the smarter
move by marvel head kevin feige you're
so smart papa figgy tell us your secrets
feige well this is actually a new series
we're trying out here at new rockstars
to try to analyze the bold decisions
made by marvel studios where they defy
conventional thinking and defy even what
fans think we want and in the case of
the character of iron man to risk making
him such a linchpin absolute point of a
character in 616 that he is truly
impossible to reboot as we venture into
the multiverse so let's break down the
timeline of feige's plan
step one make iron man an absolute mess
my friends what is the true secret to
the mcu success is it a perfectly
interconnected universe obviously not if
it was we wouldn't have to make as many
videos trying to explain the plot holes
in the loose ends i'm sorry papa don't
be mad at me papa the truth is the mcu
which is now codified as earth 616 is
broken and that's a good thing because
it has created opportunities for all
these ambitious fools to try to fix it
with grand sweeps who then of course
break it even more and has given us
multiple suspects for who actually broke
it the most and the dna of that
brokenness is actually rooted in how
kevin feige first came to partner with
john favreau and robert downey jr to
create the character of tony stark you
may remember how in the 90s a
cash-strapped marvel entertainment sold
the film rights of its most valuable
characters to other film studios
spider-man to sony hulk to universal and
the x-men fantastic four and daredevil
to fox this is actually where kevin
feige got his start as an assistant on
the first fox x-men film in 2000
actually 20 years later a retrospective
history of this film by observer
revealed that feige was the nerd in the
room who spoke up to ensure characters
maintain integrity to the comics from
there feige worked on every marvel title
partnered with other studios he said he
learned a lot from sam raimi's marvel
world building on the set of the 2002
spider-man i was there mainly watching
and learning uh on those early samurai
spider-man movies and i watched and
learned from a group of people that were
trying to exceed expectations and trying
to fulfill their own
childhood dreams and the childhood
dreams of fans of the characters then
feige moved on to 2003's daredevil
co-starring john favreau as foggy nelson
where these two met actually later on
favreau would recall advice feige
imparted onto him about the importance
to prioritize core fans alongside
newcomers to the franchise feige then
became head of marvel studios which at
first was an independent studio with
really no access to marvel comics
biggest names so in 2008 feige partnered
with paramount to release a character
that was still totally in marvel comics
control iron man and they considered
several a-listers for their front man
including yeah tom cruise but they chose
robert downey jr who after a substance
abuse scandal in the 90s had begun a bit
of a career comeback in roles like shane
black's action comedy kiss kiss bang
bang and it's funny to remember now
robert downey jr is the biggest star on
the planet what he was then was one of
the best actors on the planet not
necessarily one of the biggest marquee
stars on the planet and it was
liberating to make decisions like that
that i don't know would have been made
at other studios at the time we got
really lucky
with robert because he was doing it for
you know he was not an expensive
movie star at the time so that
redemption of downey's personal
narrative was core to his take on iron
man downed that detail of tony telling
foggy to stop for burger king
cheeseburgers which was taken from a
true story downey told of his decision
to get clean after eating fast food hung
over and throwing his drugs into the
ocean an image that shane black would
later evoke in the final shot of iron
man 3. cheeseburgers even came back in
end game as morgan stark's request to
foggy and then even in spider-man no way
home morgan's drawings and happy's condo
feature robert downey jr's hangover cure
now obviously i put a lot of time and
research into these videos making it
hard for me to put time and research
into other things things like investing
investing i thought investing had to
take a lot of time and research so i
just kept putting it off but that's
because i did not know about wealthfront
thanks to wealthfront for sponsoring
this video wealthfront is what's called
a robo advisor which doesn't mean that
it's like a giant metal box pretending
to be a high school guidance counselor
even better it's an app that uses
software to manage your investments
turns out robots are way better at
investing than telling you which
elective to take for six period they
always tell you to take computer science
it's like think outside the box box
wealthfront is trusted with over 27
billion dollars in assets helping nearly
half a million people build their wealth
they have a lot of cool tools that help
you get more from your savings like
their tax loss harvesting software that
looks for opportunities daily to help
lower your tax bill smarter folks than
me know that the key to long-term
investing is to invest early in things
like etfs and then let the robo advisors
do the work for you you can't beat them
at chess so you better believe they are
better at investing wealthfront is one
of the few companies who actually
disclose their annual returns and they
have been voted best robo advisor by
both investopedia and nerd wallet so
click the link in the description box to
try wealthfront today and get your first
five thousand dollars managed for free
people talk a lot about tony stark's
flaws as a character he's an arrogant
alcoholic paranoid futurist in spite of
his brilliant engineering but i think we
fail to remember that one of the key
reasons the first iron man works so well
is how often his armor which is his
biggest selling point doesn't work it
breaks constantly the vfx of the armor
assembly looks stunning and indeed still
holds up so much that you can see echoes
of that piecemeal tactile suit assembly
and more recent titles like moon knight
even dr strange when he jumps off a
balcony is pulling a tony stark move but
every scene with tony's hardware kicking
ass is buttoned with a clumsy face plant
the escape from the cave faceplant his
first flight crash through the roof
piano in the car rescuing the hostages
then shot down by a tank this is classic
hollywood slapstick inspired by people
like buster keaton charlie chaplin
scrappy heroes tripping and bringing
down the whole set with them and it's
really the running joke that the mcu
continues to revisit tony's brilliant
hardware always short circuits and
overheats in iron man 3 when he summoned
the mark 42 when he accidentally birthed
ultron and kicked off the series of
events that culminated in the scarlet
witch killing everything and an endgame
when his nanotech slyly snatched his
stones off thanos but left tony
vulnerable to cosmic radiation
everything broken in the mcu during the
infinity saga and maybe even beyond one
could argue was broken initially by tony
stark trying to fix things but perhaps
the most critical moment was when feign
favreau allowed downey to go off script
in the first iron man film's most
important line
i am iron man
we later learned that robert downey jr
ad-libbed this line he also ad-libbed
the callback to this moment in avengers
in-game he included the words i am iron
man among several takes of this snap
during reshoots i
it cannot be understated how big of a
deal this ad-lib was because every other
superhero franchise was defined by
secret identities but in the mcu nearly
every hero would be a public figure and
then have to deal with the consequences
of media scrutiny a subject that feige
knew would be interesting to marvel
comics readers since it was the wedge
issue of the civil war storyline that
released as they were developing the
iron man film feige allowed his broken
leading man to break the norm because as
he told favreau the nerds would stick
with them feige would go on to build a
cinematic universe with tony stark at
the center of it captain america built
with stark wizardry and became tony's
main rival spider-man a stark recruit
and a mentee hulk initially recruited by
tony and later tony's lab partner doctor
strange a wizard paying the price for
helping tony yet wisely in that very
first post-credit scene feige withheld
all of those partnerships mr stark you
become part of a bigger universe you
just don't know it yet but what i love
about this is that kevin feige
originally planned to have samuel l
jackson give a completely different line
and i'm about to show you a deleted
scene that has never been seen by anyone
before right now thank you again so much
and enjoy
as if gamma accidents radioactive bug
bites and assorted mutants weren't
enough
i have to deal with a spoiled brat who
doesn't play well with others and wants
to keep all his toys to himself
aha so bikey benched hulk bench
spiderman and bench the x-men and not
just for contractual reasons because
remember marvel was then an independent
studio that partnered with universal to
make the incredible hulk it might have
been able to partner with fox to make
mcu x-men movies back then or with sony
to do an mcu spider-man which eventually
after their disney acquisition and after
sony gave them a window they did and
there is a fascinating behind-the-scenes
drama there that not a lot of people
know we're going to cover in a future
chapter of the series so feige
absolutely could have cited radioactive
bug bites and assorted mutants but he
waited for now keeping hulk and
spider-man and the x-men out of the
scene kept the mcu all about tony stark
and his brokenness feige would go on to
do the same thing in titles like one
division withholding cameos from big
names like doctor strange or mephisto to
keep the focus on wanda and vision and
that delay made wanda a fiercer threat
to doctor strange so now that multiverse
of madness has revealed to us at least
an 838 universe filled with variant
heroes some of them now dead and
certainly requiring resurrections no
iron man variant i don't care how
superior can replicate the full extent
of the brokenness that robert downey
jr's take on the character has encoded
into the 616 universe and i'm not just
saying this the way one might make a
case for heath ledger as the definitive
joker or janet hubert as the definitive
aunt viv but really to say that kevin
feige has already designed the 616 mcu
in the infinity saga as a tony stark
cinematic universe and that other
universes we visit like 838 and any of
the other ones the overzealous frontman
role should be occupied by some other
hot mess for 838 that mess seems to be
reed richards who literally is now a
mess of string cheese on the baxter
foundation floor but for other universes
that mess could be kang or magneto or
jean grey or victor von doom their flaws
should define those universes can other
tony starks exist in those universes
sure but they probably are not going to
be the linchpin tentpole that our tony
stark was for 616. so yeah there are a
number of reasons to appreciate robert
downey jr's iron man but i think what
makes him a singular figure one
impossible to truly replace in phase
four and beyond is the way the 616 mcu
has been built in his broken image
necessity is always the mother of
invention folks and feige needed a face
to make up for his fractured universe
and now that all these titles are back
in his control those worlds are about to
be colored by other thematic flaws while
universe 616 continues to embody the
unique flaws of downey's tony stark i
want to thank you so much for watching
chapter one of this feige plan series
we'll be exploring other interesting
counter-intuitive approaches that he
took like why thor is actually unworthy
and who else will bear cap's shield so
be sure to subscribe to new rockstars
follow me on instagram and twitter at
eavos following the rockstars thank you
for watching bye
[Music]
foreign
[Music]